hello Internet
welcome to film theory one of the few
series that managed to make a successful
crossover from video games to the movies
I got Matt Prince of Persia but
seriously let's get right into today's
theory because it's one I'm pretty darn
excited about the new Suicide Squad
movie is coming out and none of the
trailers have shown doomsday yet so
overall I'm fairly optimistic of what
the trailers have shown is one of my
all-time favorite comic book villains
the Joker another thing I've always
loved about this guy is the mystery that
just follows him everywhere who is he
one of the longest held questions about
the Batman universe the recently DC a
star to tip their hand emits at least in
the comics in Justice League number 42
Batman gains access to the Mobius chair
an intergalactic chair that has all the
knowledge in the universe after Batman
sits in the chair he tests it by asking
a question that only he knows the answer
to who killed his parents and the chair
gets it right so with the chairs
successfully proving that it knows all
or at least saw the opening minutes of
practically every Batman movie ever made
Batman asks the most important question
of all know not who thought the Martha
thing was a good idea in Batman V
Superman or what was the deal with the
bat nipple suit but the question that's
been on everyone's mind since the
earliest days of the comics who is the
Joker
we actually don't get to hear the möbius
chairs answer only Batman's stunned
reaction then eight issues and a year
later and Justice League number 50 we
finally learn what the Mobius chair told
Batman now if you thought Game of
Thrones has frustrating cliffhangers
then you're gonna love this one
and the issue Batman reveals that the
Mobius chair told him that they were not
one not two but three different jokers
what way to milk it DC and of course the
internet lit up with theories no Batman
character was safe Alfred clearly the
Joker Robin also the Joker Batman
himself somehow still the Joker but your
guess as to why is just as good as mine
so yeah that's all well and good but to
me the coolest part of this reveal
wasn't so much of the implications for
the comics but rather the implications
for the movies because if there are
three Joker's in the comics could there
also be three different Joker's in the
you see film universe no that's not as
ridiculous as it sounds just look at the
man behind all of this geoff johns he's
a legendary comic writer and wrote
justice league number 42 and number 50
the issues dealing with this Mobius
chair he's the man responsible for DC
rebirth and recently it was announced
that he would be Co running DC films
he's literally the man whose job it is
to translate the universe of the comics
on to the screen so if someone anyone is
gonna adhere to this monumental reveal
from the comics it's gonna be him and
looking at the Batman's that are already
in the movies surprisingly the theory
holds up to this point there have only
been three live-action interpretations
of the Joker in the 1966 Batman the
movie the Joker was played by cesar
romero then in the 1989 Tim Burton
Batman the Joker was reinvented by Jack
Nicholson and of course in the 2008
Chris Nolan sequel the Dark Knight Heath
Ledger reinterpreted him yet again sure
there have been animated versions of the
character sprinkled in throughout but in
terms of just live-action it's a perfect
fit but those are all the Joker's of the
past we now have the inclusion of
Suicide Squad and its new Joker played
by Jared Leto that makes four different
live-action Joker's so what gives well
what if it turned out that Jared Leto's
Joker wasn't a new Joker but instead
picking up the baton for one of the ones
we've already seen in the past a huge
deal for the cinematic DC Universe but
it begs the question which one would he
be and is there even any proof that this
assertion is even worth testing well to
find out for sure we'll need to know a
little bit more about the other three
Joker's and see how the Batman comic and
movies collide the history of comics can
be divided into four distinct periods
the Golden Age of 1938 to 1950 the
Silver Age of 1956 to 1970 the Bronze
Age of 1970 to 1985 and the modern age
of 1985 to today and comics changed a
whole bunch across those different ages
and along with them portrayals of the
Joker now the Golden Age was when the
first superhero comics like Superman
Batman and Wonder Woman were first being
published they became really popular
right after the Great Depression and
during World War two at a time when the
u.s. really needed larger-than-life
heroes and
result feature patriotic heroes doing
battle against uh let's just say
foreign-looking foes it was during this
age that the Joker made his first
appearance in the 1940 Batman number one
this first Joker was a deranged serial
killer with a sadistic sense of humor in
the first issue ever Joker announces on
the radio that he plans to steal a
diamond and murder a guy that it just
does it he just goes and does it in
Batman's first 12 issues he kills dozens
of people and does some pretty sick
stuff like burn smiles on to all his
victims faces and makes masks out of
people's skin people's skin is this the
comics or Silence of the Lambs
cheeese the Golden Age of comics wasn't
just superhero stories though there were
actually all kinds of comics horror
crime westerns romance and they weren't
just for kids either a lot of them had
themes that were pretty darn adults in
the middle of the 1950's anti-communist
paranoia though Fredrick Werdum released
the seduction of the innocent where he
blamed comic books for all juvenile
delinquency hmm sound familiar obviously
as people began to get more sensitive
there became an increased call to tone
down the violence of these books however
instead of waiting for the government to
censor them comic book publishers
censored themselves in 1954 the comics
code Authority was formed to review and
approve comics by their own rules rules
like quote crimes shall never be
presented to create sympathy for the
criminal romance story shall emphasize
the value of the home and the sanctity
of marriage and all scenes of horror
bloodshed gory or gruesome crimes shall
not be permitted as well as 37 other
rules with these changes began the
Silver Age of comics the Silver Age
often referred to as the age of
innocence it's all about fantasy and
optimism
since crime and horror were heavily
regulated superheroes started battling
monsters and aliens instead of people
the greediness of the Golden Age was
gone and replaced with campy humor and
the Joker was no exception in the 1950s
and 60s the Joker went from being a mass
murderer to being just a prankster he
was like a tamer version of Roman Atwood
all the Joker wanted during the Silver
Age was cash in fact in a 1952 issue
Joker's Millions the Joker inherits a
massive fortune and just retires from
crime altogether peace out guys I'm done
until of course at
out that the whole fortune is
counterfeit I hate when that happens the
Joker here never kills or even harms
anyone
it's like Looney Tunes with Elmer Fudd
and Bugs Bunny where he just basically
gets out pranked by Batman this is also
the time when he got all his gadgets
hand buzzer spitting flower trick guns
even his own car The Joker mobile it
took twenty years but eventually people
got sick of the saccharine comics code
Authority and basically stopped
following it assuring in the Bronze Age
now the Bronze Age of comics brought the
medium back to a place where it could
address social issues and return them to
their darker roots this is where iron
man dealt with alcoholism
spider-man's girlfriend Gwen Stacy died
and the Joker became a murderer once
again yay the difference between this
and the Golden Age though is that now
there was a big emphasis on the
psychology of these characters for
instance in 1973's the Joker's five-way
revenge the Joker escapes from an insane
asylum and systematically kills the five
men who ratted him out this new version
of the Joker emphasized his insanity and
mental instability instead of being an
evil master criminal or a goofy
prankster the new Joker is a mentally
ill psychopath who chooses not to
control his own actions the modern age
of comics double down on this dark and
gritty imagery the best example is the
Dark Knight Returns which was a comic
before it was a movie prize and just
like the movie the comics emphasize the
fact that the Joker can function or
practically even exist without Batman as
his counterparts the yin to his yang all
of this should be sounding familiar so
we have three ages of comics and three
Joker's the criminal mastermind the
goofy prankster and the psychopath when
Jeff Jones announced that there were
three different Joker's in Justice
League number 50 he was basically
explaining away how the character has
evolved over the past 80 years it can be
interpreted that the three Joker's of
the gold silver and bronze modern age
have now just become their own separate
characters but if it's true in the
comics does it also work in the movies
surprisingly yes because when you look
at it the three film versions of the
Joker seamlessly correspond to the three
comic versions the 1966 Cesar Romero
Joker is the Silver Age one a goofy
prankster with Caray easy
teams constantly outwitted by Batman
Romero's Joker isn't a murderer or
sadistic madman he's just a thief
obsessed with robbing banks and art
museums and much like the Silver Age
Joker Romero's version uses a variety of
gadgets a spraying flower a utility belt
hand buzzers gas grenades and yes even
his own car The Joker mobile Tim
Burton's 1989 Jack Nicholson Joker is a
completely different tape which makes
sense because he's the Golden Age
version the Nicholson Joker's origin
follows the exact same story that's
given to the Golden Age Joker where he's
a career criminal who slips into a vat
of chemicals after being cornered by
Batman he's disfigured and when he sees
his reflection at the surgeon's office
he goes completely insane reinventing
himself as the Joker beat for beat like
the comic Nicholson's Joker is also a
serious killer contorting his victims
faces into permanent smiles with toxins
the same calling card as the Golden Age
Joker the Nicholson Joker also announces
his plans on television just as the
Golden Age Joker announced his plans on
the radio in Batman number one they even
used the exact same flesh makeup
technique which leaves us with the
obvious one the Heath Ledger Joker the
tragic psychopath he tells Batman that
he can't live without him and that
they're destined to be adversaries
forever
people are constantly stating how crazy
Ledger's Joker is how unpredictable he
is which reflects the bronze and modern
ages focus on his unstable psyche some
men just washed it so there you have it
all three Joker's fit cleanly into the
three Joker comic model but then that
prompts the question now that Jared Leto
is playing the Joker in Suicide Squad is
he a whole new character or which Joker
line would he be continuing are we
actually gonna be getting to Suicide
Squad now Moebius chair tell me who is
Jared Leto's Joker what you sure no I'm
not questioning you but what sort of
proof do you have
oh that makes a lot of sense actually
yeah that would make a really good
episode I don't have to do that thing
where there's a cliffhanger and I hate
those things and TV shows it's like the
worst I haven't even done Doctor Who
part 3 at Mobius chair whoa what did the
Mobius chair tell matpat who really is
Jared Leto's Joker would they really end
on a cliffhanger after just forcing you
to wait for part 2 of don't hug me I'm
scared
unbelievable subscribe so you can join
us next week on film theory to find out
and while you're in the mood for more
Joker action make sure you click right
here to check out the wisecrack channels
video on the philosophy of the Joker
revealing the characters original
inspirations the true meaning behind his
motives and how his evolution over the
years reflects the current state of our
times the folks over at wisecrack always
delivering loads of education with loads
of laughs do check them out and do make
sure that you're here next week for the
thrilling conclusion of this batch saga
and in the meantime remember that's just
a theory a film theory
and cut